what about Robert E Lee so he's the
confederate general that you mentioned
yeah uh was he a hero or villain to me
he's a villain many people treat Robert
E Lee as a hero and one of the points I
make in the book is we have to rethink
that and it's very important for our
society because Robert E Lee pops up all
over our society names of schools names
of streets and he also embeds and
justifies certain behaviors that I think
are really bad Lee was a was a
tremendous General he had the weaker
side and he managed to use maneuver
secrecy and Circumstance to give himself
so many advantages and win so many
battles he should have lost so in terms
of the technical generalship uh he's a
great General uh but Lee at the end of
the war never wants to really
acknowledge defeat what he acknowledges
at Appomattox is that his soldiers will
have to leave the battlefield because
they have not won on the battlefield but
he refuses to do what Grant asks him
which is to help sell his side on the
fact that we're going into a post-war
moment where they don't have to see
themselves as losers but they have to
get on board with change real leadership
is convincing people who follow you that
they have to change when they don't want
to change Lee refuses to do that he says
to Grant I quote this in the book he
says to granted Appomattox if you want
to change the South you have to run your
army over the South three or four times
he's not going to do anything he's not
going to help and uh he becomes a figure
who people rally around and in the rest
of his life and even after he dies so it
is as if
at the end of World War II
Hitler had been allowed to just retire
and he didn't go back into politics but
yet he was there and he continued to
have meetings with former Nazis and
people would rally around the idea of
bringing back or going back to Hitler's
ideas think of how harmful that would be
Lee played that kind of of role after
the war and I think it's one of the
problems we have now I don't think we
should continue to Revere him because it
justifies too much of what the
Confederates stood for
and that's the difference that you
highlight between World War II and the
Civil War that in the case of Hitler
there was there was a there was an end
to that war there's a very distinctive
clear end to that war and you also uh
make the case that World War II is not a
good example not a good model of a war
to help us analyze history it's given
Americans the wrong idea what war is
because World War II ends as most wars
don't end World War II ends with a
complete defeat
of the German Army and the German
society and the near complete defeat of
Japan
and where both sides in different ways
except defeat
what I'm pointing out in the book is
that most wars don't accept with one
side don't end with one side accepting
defeat and uh generally the war
continues after the battles and this is
something that's hard for Americans to
understand our system is built with the
presumption of a war is over when we
signed a piece of paper everyone can go
home
it's not what happens I mean Civil War
is a special case it's especially a
strong case of that because the people
that fought the War is still living in
that land that's exactly right and in
this case some of them are leaders also
many of them become the leaders of the
very areas that they were leading before
uh and I think that's another lesson
here too that we did undertake after
World War II though in a flawed way we
had a Nuremberg system we did prohibit
at least Nazi leaders from coming back
into power we made an exception for the
emperor in Japan but we generally
followed the same rule in Japan whereas
in the United States
as I point out many of the leaders of
the Confederacy first of all don't
surrender they flee to Mexico
then they come back after they lose in
Mexico a second time they come back to
the United States and they get elected
to office
uh the guy who writes the election laws
in Texas Alexander Watkins Terrell most
people don't know this even in Texas he
was a confederate general fled to Mexico
so he committed treason by joining the
Army of Maximilian emperor of Mexico who
was put in power by Louis Napoleon after
Max Millions defeated Alexander Watkins
Terrell comes back to Texas runs for the
state legislature and then writes the
election laws it's crazy can you make
the case for that that that's a feature
of the American system not a bug that
that is an implementation of justice
that you forgive that you don't
persecute everybody on the other side of
the war maybe and I think that's a good
feature in terms of lower level
individuals but I think a bad feature of
our system is we do allow
elite figures who have committed
wrongdoing we give them many ways to get
out of punishment you are more likely to
be punished in this Society if you do
something wrong and you're not an elite
figure then if you're on a leader there
should be a proportional like
forgiveness should be equally
distributed across and it's not yeah and
it's not
but we could change it we could fix that
how do we fix that but how do how do we
fix that what I think was argued at the
end this is one of the really important
things about studying history you learn
about ideas that were not pursued that
could be pursued today uh at the end of
the Civil War there was there was an
effort to ban anyone who was in a
leadership position in the Confederacy
from ever serving in federal office
again that's the third uh element of the
14th Amendment it's in the 14th
Amendment the 14th Amendment Clause 3
says that if you took an oath of office
meaning you were elected to office
you're an elite figure and you violated
that oath you can still live in the
country you can still get rich but you
can't run for elected office again yeah
and that what we we've never really uh
implemented that is it obvious that
everybody who's in a leadership position
on the Confederate side
is a bad person for the future of the
United States
or is that just a safe thing to assume
for the future of the nation I think
it's the latter you know maybe people do
things for all kinds of reasons and
sometimes they have regrets that's also
why we have the pardoning capability you
could pardon someone individually if
they show you that that they've changed
yeah and it would only create fairness
because right now let's say Lex you take
out a huge huge loan and you don't pay
your loan back that will go on your
credit
and you won't get a big loan again
you don't get to say
just give me another chance you're gonna
have to prove
I think about holding public office in
the same way
if you've violated your credit rating on
that you should have a much higher road
to go to prove to us that you should be
back in office